one of the major gripes that I have with
the red pill and the red pill has been
extremely beneficial in enhancing my
knowledge with regards to intersexual
relationship Dynamics but one of my
major gripes is that on the one hand a
lot of red pillars will speak quite
vehemently against women with high body
counts but then on the other hand we
don't mind giving men top color top
Caliber men top 10 one percent men a
free pass to sleep with women
indiscriminately as a reward for them
having reached the upper echelon of
earners basically and this is why Islam
comes and it Fetters this this polygyny
basically it Fitters a man it says it's
okay you can have multiple women if
you're able to take care of them okay so
there are prerequisites you're able to
house them and take care of them and so
on and you can have up to four you can
have four women no problem but anything
above and beyond that that's prohibited